tell me everything that happened the
first time I visited death row I wasn't
expecting to meet somebody the same age
as me from a neighborhood just like ours
could have been me mama but what you're
doing is gonna make a lot of people
upset you always taught me to fight for
the people who need to help most your
life is still meaningful and I'm gonna
do everything possible to keep them from
taking you all know what you into down
here now Tibetan when you get it from
the moment you're born God mr. macmillan
we done here mr. macmillan please I was
just about to give up when I got a call
from a Harvard lawyer looking to start a
legal center for inmates on death row I
was in before he even offered me the job
Yuda lawyer yes ma'am thank you so much
for driving all the way out here most
lawyers barely make time to call I can't
believe you talked to all my people see
I'm fine for me
I did I mean a lot you know digging in
those wounds you're gonna be making a
lot of people very unhappy
when people care about a thing that much
tell me anything to get what they want
when I first learned about all this it
was like looking at a river full of
drowning people and not having any way
of helping them
[Music]
your quickness no sir
each of us is more than the worst thing
that we've ever done I know what it's
like to be in the shadows
[Music]
it's my dad
he did nothing wrong
it's never too late for justice
you don't want kid enough to fight for
me
if we can look at our self close
we can change this world for the better
we all need grace
we all need mercy
I cannot shoot back you get your head
telling and ain't nobody gonna take
their phones
you